vsauce michael here coming by a webcam
in Kansas I'm headed back to NYC
tomorrow but I wanted to send you 10
quick vsauce video game WTF i was
inspired by a CJ 2010's comment about
some snow humpers and doodle jump I
couldn't find video confirming this but
Vsauce keep your eyes open moving on the
proper way to decorate a Christmas tree
or if it's too violent for you here's a
cute secret pet in hell's highway just
kidding it's a weapon
you can [ __ ] it and shoot lasers out of
its face or if you prefer check out this
custom map from Team Fortress 2 where
you fight against laser cats well just
one giant laser cannon
but oblivion might have an even creepier
creature a Flying Spaghetti Monster that
gets angry and anger is only matched by
these riot shields a more graceful
movement can be found in this early
Cataclysm glitch where minions succubi
could use whiplash to fling people to
stomach-turning heights to make up for
that long fall here's video of an
incredible lease ad nude patch for Wow
oh and if you put the second player in a
bubble for an entire new Super Mario
Brothers we level and hit a when you
reach the flagpole you win but disappear
and nothing happens ever I think this is
what hell will be like but this has got
to be heaven develop earth Rex is
working on a connect sex game where you
can air fondle girls all the demo videos
have been removed from YouTube and
Microsoft says it will never leave the
game but here's something that does
exist
click the boat to watch a new show on
vsauce2 called boat it's where you guys
get to decide the best of all time this
week flash mobs
[Music]